I just a heads up so my slides are gonna
have code on the sides of the screen if
anyone wants to scoot in early on now
would be the time to do so cool so it's
really great to be here my name is
Leland Richardson as Jason said I I work
at Google I work on the Android UI
toolkit team on a project called jetpack
compose so show of hands that who here
has actually heard of jetpack compose
okay some people so let's let's dive in
and say okay what is what is compose
so first and foremost composed is a
declarative UI runtime it's a component
based UI framework much like react in
fact many of the api's were inspired by
react and other frameworks that you're
probably familiar with
it's a Kotlin compiler plugin as well so
we we do some compile time optimizations
and we actually plug it in to the Colin
compiler and so that means that if you
want to use Jeff I compose you do need
to write your code in Kotlin and Kotlin
if you're not familiar with it is the is
the language that you can use for
Android it is now Android is now in
calling first platform and jetpack
compos'd is built by the it's built by
Google it's built by the thread UI
toolkit team themselves so this is the
same people that maintain do Java for
instance now composed is sort of like
three parts there's the runtime there's
the compiler and then there's also what
we call compose UI and compose UI is a
complete ground-up rewrite of the
Android UI toolkit and so this means
that the entire
UI framework that you think of when you
think of Android is sort of actively
being rewritten on top of this new
programming model and runtime this is a
really big undertaking but I'm actually
not gonna be talking much about this
today and I'm mostly going to be
focusing on the runtime and how it works
and what that might mean to you so
compose UI and the runtime and
everything else is completely unbundled
from the underlying Android operating
system we do this for several reasons
but a big one is just so that we can
actually iterate on things and release
new features and so people like you
don't have to wait for phone
manufacturers or anything like that to
upgrade the operating system it's just a
user space library and it's also open
source so as of Google i/o we started
developing working on this in the open
and so you can go and kind of see what
what we're working on how things work if
you really want to dive into it
contribute any of that but the kicker is
it's really not ready to use that it's
not even alpha its pre alpha so if you
know look at this talk as me just sort
of talking about it and sort of things
that I find interesting and I think you
might find interesting not trying to
sell it to you right now is like a thing
to actually use
so obviously I'm pretty excited about
this I work on it but here I am at a
react conference and I'm talking about
this Android thing and some of you might
be like well why is he here talking
about this how is this actually relevant
to me and that that might be a fair
question
I assume some people in the audience
might be Android developers maybe in a
past life things like that but I I think
really I just want us to take a step
back and really look at the mobile UI
development landscape right now and some
of you might be aware that recently
Apple released Swift UI and so this is
pretty interesting what we're starting
to see just in the last couple of months
is that
like three of the world's largest
companies are investing a ton of time
into declarative UI frameworks and
really this kind of represents I don't
know I think that we've like past an
inflection point declarative UI is now
the way to build UI and that that's kind
of cool because we you know I I was a
big part of the react community for a
long time still AM I think and it's it's
kind of like hey we were right like this
is this is a really powerful way to do
things people are taking notice and so
this is this is a really cool time and
so I kind of want to try and play my
part in that time and kind of introduce
all of you to compose and really talk
about how in this environment we're a
big company you know said hey let's
let's build something and invest a lot
of time and energy into making it the
right thing how does that look different
from react and how does it look similar
and I think there's really a lot of
interesting differences here and so this
talk is actually kind of a technical
deep dive so get get prepared jet pack
composed has a very similar programming
model to react it you'll see some slides
soon it should look fairly familiar to
you
but the execution model is actually
quite different and so we're going to
talk about some of those differences and
what they mean
both compose and react have kind of
target functions as the fundamental
building block function components are
our thing and react and they're actually
the only thing in compose and so to turn
a function into a component you annotate
it with a composable annotation and we
can see here this is caught one on the
right looks pretty similar react
actually you pass it in a props object
it's kind of one big bag of properties
whereas in composed we actually use the
individual parameters as the properties
and so here's where things start to get
interesting if you look on the
right-hand side there's sort of a an
ominously missing return statement
so in react you actually return the
result of of JSX right you returned a
blob of JSX and composed you actually
just execute other composable functions
and it kind of does the same thing and
you can kind of think of it very
similarly the two pieces of code looked
the same and actually you can kind of
think that the JSX element itself is
kind of like an invocation of a
composable function and we can kind of
see the similarities here on both sides
now when we're just invoking functions
how do we kind of make it look
structural we're kind of building trees
and we want it to feel that way and you
can actually see here in Kotlin we have
these curly braces to the right of the
the function call and that's actually
syntax for a lambda but the lambda in
this syntax which is called trailing
lambda syntax is implicitly passed into
the function as the last parameter to
that function and so this kind of gives
us this structural nesting of elements
that that kind of looks familiar and so
this means that if you're a composable
function and you want to accept children
you would add a children parameter or
any name that you want and the type of
that would be a composable lambda and so
we can see that over here we would kind
of be how that would work so we're now
kind of seeing some of these differences
in compose I actually execute these
functions whereas in react I'm returning
this data structure and a lot of a lot
of you may have heard this referred to
as a virtual Dom or something this is
this is basically a lightweight data
structure that JSX creates for you and
the equivalent in compose isn't really
there we're not returning anything but
we do need to do a lot of the same
things that react does which is you know
kind of handle inserts and deletes and
moves and the sort of reconciliation
pass and the way we do that is we
actually store things in a linear array
and that array is getting passed around
by the compiler all that is kind of done
for you and we're going to show you a
little bit of that
so also when you're building sort of
these.you is you need to introduce state
at some point and react you can do that
with a use state hook and and compose
you have a similar sort of concept
though there's a state function for
instance that returns a value and you
can use that as state and you can see
how these look pretty similar you can
even make it more similar if you want to
using Cullen's destructuring syntax but
basically the the programming model here
is the same so let's go into this
execution model which we're seeing now
is kind of a little different a primary
sort of data structure that we use for
compose it's actually called a gap
buffer if any of you have heard of a gap
buffer it's commonly used in text
editors it's a data structure that
allows you to efficiently update text in
the context of editing but we actually
use it for our runtime and internally we
we sort of call it a slot table so you
might hear me say that
so slot table gap buffer kind of the
same thing and this gap buffer
represents a sort of a linear collection
of items underlying it is a flat array
contiguous array in memory and here I'm
just representing an empty one and that
empty part of the array is sort of
considered the gap and if I want to
start inserting items into this array I
can do that and keep adding items and
the gap essentially gets smaller right I
don't have those items or I don't have
those slots in the a'ready to use so I'm
inserting these items
what if I want to go back and start
running code on top of that array what I
can do is if I want to keep the same
item in there I can just increment an
index if I want to update an item in
there I can change it and then if I want
to insert items I actually first move
the gap to that index and then I can
insert an item I can insert more items
and sort of keep going and so the point
here is that essentially every operate
every array
based operation here is constant time
the only thing that is not constant time
is moving the gap and so the bet that
we're making is that most you eyes don't
change structurally all that often and
so we won't have to move the gap all
that often and we do it'll be kind of be
good for that big insert and so this is
sort of the the trade-off that we're
making so we want to see how that looks
in practice let's take this counter
component and let's do the sugar this
syntax a little bit so I took away that
composable annotation and then I added
these parameters to the function and
that's kind of what our compiler is
doing to a real simple level and then
we're adding some calls to this
synthetic composer parameter in the body
of the function and I'm going to kind of
walk you through what that's doing and
you can see that also the I have taken
that composer parameter and I've passed
it in to all of the other composable
functions that I'm calling in the body
so the compiler kind of threads it
through for you but in addition to that
I my compiler has added these integers
and there's just these kind of numbers
the the way you should think of them is
that they're sort of like a hash of the
unique source position for the call site
of that composable function and so this
number kind of uniquely identifies its
position in the code so when we're
executing through this function we run
in the composer got start kind of stores
this group object into the array we go
and call state and it's going to store
another group into the array with one
two three and then state itself might do
something and it's gonna store this
state value in the table then we move on
to button and it's gonna create another
group and it's gonna start storing these
parameters and then the actual button
function itself might go and do a bunch
of other stuff but we're not going into
that but we're just going to represent
it here in the bottom of the array so
we've gone through this component and
the way to look at this is that the the
execution of all of these functions that
I'm doing sort of form an implicit
hierarchy it's like the execution graph
of
my entire UI and that graph that that
tree is stored in this array sort of as
like a depth-first traversal of it but
we're actually taking up a lot of room
with these groups here and it's kind of
unclear why they're needed so the the
groups are actually needed to deal with
the shape of that graph changing over
time and in react this is kind of what
the virtual DOM is used for it's to
understand when something changes but
here since we're a compiler we can
actually know kind of statically when
one of those things is going to change
and when it's not it turns out these
groups are almost never needed they're
actually only needed for control flow so
in most cases we don't need to put them
in there but let's look at an example
where we do need to put them in there
which is for control flow one such
example is an if statement and so here
we have a component that gets in data if
that is null it renders the loading like
screen or something and then if it's not
and all it renders something else so the
kind of D sugared version of this from
the compiler is going to look something
like this and actually each block of the
F is going to have its own little group
like we had before and we see that we no
longer need to pass in a key to the
function so if we go through here we're
basically going to create a group call
loading and then we're kind of done and
that's that's how this sort of part of
the UI is representing in the graph if
we go back and now there's data we're
going to enter in a different block of
the if and so at this point the runtime
is going to look at the the integer here
the key let's see 4 5 6 doesn't equal 1
2 3 and at this point it knows that it
needs to make a change and it knows that
the structure of the UI is changed and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to move the gap up to the current
position and then we're essentially
going to remove the the group from
before and start adding the new one and
this gets stored in the array like so
and so we can see that these groups are
important for control flow like for
loops if if State
and stuff like that but actually almost
nowhere else and that that's that's
pretty valuable now we've saved a lot of
space and we've kind of learned how to
utilize this this backing cache while
still having arbitrary control flow and
this concept is what we call positional
memorization so this combination of
using a gap buffer cache and then using
the execution of kind of arbitrary code
and and having that backing cache
threaded through the the concept
positional memoization is what we came
up with and this is basically the
fundamental piece of compose this is
what compose is built on and so let's
look at a more elementary example
memoization if that's an unfamiliar term
for you it's basically just a fancy word
for cache ending result of a function
based on the inputs of the function and
so here would be a common example of
where memoization might make sense we've
got an app component we've got items and
a query string and then inside the body
of our function were doing some
computational work in this case we're
like filtering a list based on a query
and getting a refined set of results
what we can do is we can wrap that
calculation with a call to this function
called memo and we're passing that in
and we're assuming that this this code
works basically the same way and it does
that by using this gap buffer cache that
we're we're talking about so when we run
into memo we store the input so we store
items into the cache and we store the
the query parameter these are the inputs
and since we haven't ever run this
component before we also have to run the
calculation and we're gonna store the
result and then we get it back and then
we just kind of continue but the next
time we run this function we're gonna
have that we're gonna be at the same
position of that of that array and so
we're gonna go and instead of storing
items we're gonna first check to see if
it matches the the previous execution
and if it does we're going to check the
next one and if that does then we don't
need to run the cup
we can just pull out the result and
throw it back
and so this memo function is kind of
like a very fundamental piece for how we
can start to to kind of efficiently
build up maintain and update our UI and
one of the interesting pieces of this is
actually a sort of a degenerate case for
memoization
let's imagine that we took a memo and we
actually memorized a calculation that
wasn't pure and it wasn't really
expected to be so here we're memorizing
math not random and this actually kind
of changes the semantics of the code
what what happens now is that we've
we've generated a random number but now
we're gonna keep reusing that same
random number each time each each time
the the hierarchy sort of gets
regenerated or re-rendered if you will
if you think about it that's kind of
like persistence in a way and so one of
the big realizations that we had is that
you can think of an under specified
positional memoization as equivalent to
persistence and persistence gives rise
to what we all sort of call state and so
we can create this state function here
just using this this memo function and
actually I'm not going to get into it
there's a lot of other real fundamental
things that you can think of that that
are sort of based on this primitive here
and because we're appealing to that
cache we're gonna add this at composable
annotation that's sort of an indication
that this function is appealing to this
slot table gap buffer thing right and so
now that this function works this way
just like a component works this way we
can do some things that are kind of cool
so hooks have this limitation right now
and in react where you you can't use
them at the root of the function you can
only or you can only use them at the
root of the function and in compose we
can we can use this State thing inside
of a for loop or inside of an if
statement or whatever and the reason we
can do that is the same reason that we
can put components inside of a for loop
and
and an if-statement and things like that
and they work very similar and so one of
the kind of things to come away with
this is that a a react component is kind
of equivalent to a composable function
but oh sorry but also reacts hooks are
kind of equivalent to a composable
function and so the composable function
is kind of a more fundamental primitive
in this sense and the the interesting
thing to me is that compose overall its
execution model is actually really close
to react hooks and it's execution model
but pretty far from react components
execution model and the reconciliation
model that react has so that's I don't
know kind of interesting to me but let's
take this another step further so let's
imagine that we have an address
component which you know takes in State
City Street stuff like that and we're
just kind of combining them into
different text nodes and then we have
another component Google which is kind
of wrapping this component with a couple
of things sort of automatically passed
in all right when when we execute this
with with compose we see that the the
parameters are going to get stored in
the slot table something like this and
so the parameters are mapped here and
then we see that actually there's sort
of this redundancy we're storing the
same values again when we execute
address and and so this is this is kind
of an efficient this is redundant
information that we're storing and so
what if we what if we didn't have to
what if a compiler we could kind of get
rid of this inefficiency and so when we
look at the Google component what if we
added another parameter here which was
like a bit field that we're just calling
static here and now what I could do is I
could pass another value into the next
composable that determines which of
those parameters I know are static and
then the address component could take
advantage of that information
and say okay any of the any of the any
other parameters that are static of mine
I'm not gonna store I'm not gonna look
at I'm not gonna do anything I don't
need to I know they're gonna be the same
the whole time and so don't worry about
the bitwise logic that's going on here
you don't have to write that as user the
compiler is good at writing that humans
aren't so we'll take care of it
but what this allows is basically all of
these redundant pieces of data that
we've been storing we can get rid of
those in the slot table and even more
there's all of these values that are
left which are essentially all of the
string literal values that we have in
and there and those are static too so we
can get rid of those and so this whole
thing kind of washes away to just two
slots we're just storing the number and
and you know this string concatenation
and when you start to do this it gets
kind of interesting because we say okay
now this the the whole the whole sub
hierarchy here is just purely determined
by this one number you know parameter
and so what if I generate a code that
looked at the number and then looked at
the previous version of the number and
then said skip yeah if it hasn't changed
we don't need to do any of that again
and so we actually generate that code
and that code starts to look or feel a
lot like what y'all might consider I
should component update method and so we
we do this component level skipping and
a lot of places but our compiler kind of
determines what places it's safe to do
so and correct to do so and adds the
code in for you and you just write code
that takes in these parameters and and
executes the code that you want so here
we are a chain react 2019 I'm talking
about compose and like how does this all
relate to react native and and what are
we going to do here so Jetpack composed
is kind of being going to be one of one
of the ways to write UI on android and
eventually react native might want to
and doing so is actually kind of
counter-intuitively maybe a little bit
difficult react is kind of built to
target and imperative UI framework and
it's not very good at targeting a
declarative UI framework even though it
is one and so one of the things I'm
really interested in is like how could
this work and and sort of knowing the
inner workings of of compose what can we
do and I think it has to be at a more
fundamental level to actually work I
think we need to you know really kind of
think about how we can how we can form
this bridge here
and maybe have these these two
frameworks interrupt but also you know
how can react native learn from from the
this new way of doing things and is
there any sort of lessons that we can
take take back anyway so I don't I don't
know exactly what it would look like but
I hope this talk story gives a good
starting point and I want to kind of
leave you today just with this message
that you know the landscape is really
evolving and this is a pretty exciting
time I think 10 years from now we're
gonna kind of look back and think like
wow wasn't it weird when like everyone
started doing declared UI at the same
time and it all happened at once and I
don't know so anyway I just think you
know embrace it be curious investigate
how these things work it's open source
come take a look come talk to me
anything you want to do there's
literally engineer centuries being
invested into these frameworks at both
Google and Apple it'd be a shame if we
didn't collaborate you know or just talk
to each other and sort of everything is
the same it's the same programming model
but everything is also different you
know it's these frameworks are being
built with clean slates and with with
the benefit of hindsight that react
didn't necessarily have and I think
it'll be really interesting to see how
these models are different when you know
when they really get to maturity anyway
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]